the gyro can experience well I love dogs
too I love animals and this that's
something that people have a weird
problem with but they don't have a weird
problem with loving animals and feeding
their animals animals like I have
friends who fucking are vegans and they
have cats and I'm like do you understand
that cats only eat meat it's not like a
dog a dog can eat carrots a dog can eat
grains got dogs eat rice like if I have
a friend who cooks for his dog and he
gets his dog ground beef and mixes it
with potatoes and rice and it's
delicious you do that for your dog oh
yeah it doesn't a probably himself but
yeah but you can't do that with a cat if
you're gonna do with a cat it has to be
just animal protein that's it that's
really the only thing that cat is
allowed to eat yeah you can't feed cats
grains cats are not supposed to eat rice
that's supposed to eat carrots cats eat
fish and the chicken and the beef and
the liver and they they eat animal
protein they're carnivores there's
straight Carnaval so for you to be a
vegan and have a fucking cat living in
your house like you're involved in the
killing of animals whether you like it
or not I mean I guess there's probably
some vegan cat food but I can't imagine
you let's do it right now they'd
probably kill the cat it's probably not
good vegan cat food bad let's let's look
up that cats what a diligent Livius yeah
that's that's one of my two phobias cats
okay
vegan cat food you know I just would
imagine that shit is not good that
basically mini lions
Oleg says actually and the vegan cat
foods contained adequate amounts is it
okay to raise a cat vegan hmm I think
it's hilarious by the way I think that
is Virgo Alerus now artists and
activists with more than one feline the
family in Ithaca New York more in her
partner sure aya Goulding that means
they're lesbians what a surprise
lesbian vegans with cats that's crazy
you never hear about that relatively
small but deeply dedicated group of
vegan pet owners who believe their cats
and villain diets should reflect their
own beliefs about the treatment of
animals and the environmentally
sustainable sustainable lifestyles is it
okay to give your diet of mm-hmm
spare me on the phone outrage
be outraged the billions of land animals
and trillions of sea animals tortured
and killed each year in the u.s. torch
it alone for food to feed people and
pets oh man you know you leave a cat
outside that cats gonna kill a bird that
that's sweet kitty cat that you have as
a murderer yeah my cat makes these crazy
noises when he looks outside he sees
like something like a squirrel his
little jaw starts going they start their
jaws start moving up and down like they
can't help it like they're just thinking
about biting Tilly have you ever had
fight dreams like what you wake up
kicking you know you know those dreams
well cats have those when they see a
fucking animal they want to kill it's
like that they have reflex looks out the
window yeah have you ever watched them
like stork stalk you stalk your leg and
then watch a lion there is very little
difference
you're like a line crawling through the
grass or a cat crawling through your
carpet yeah like they look identical oh
yeah absolutely identical they're
murderers bro they have fucking
murderers apparently what they're saying
is for a lot of these a lot of these
people that are they're making these
these diets for these dogs there's like
a big debate whether or not it's healthy
for the dogs it's about the figure yeah
eating diets for dogs and cats whether
or not it's a matter of the animal
getting all the proper nutrients or just
being able to stay alive so I don't
really understand people's relationships
with dogs in that sense like I get the
whole like man having a dog but people
get weird so like we had we know a a
friend of a friend who told us they have
a patient who's got Munchausen's you
know Munchausen's yeah you know which is
basically so they basically make up
things so that you can get their dog
operated on like it's just like as in
problems so that they have an excuse to
get yeah an operation on the dollar but
just like like it's like their kid
apparently what they're saying is that
dogs and cats have a much different
nutritional requirement than human
beings and that the they need much
higher protein
in tech then a human does so especially
dogs can eat a bunch of other shit like
yams and potatoes and all these
different other things it's okay
as long as they get sufficient amount of
protein but it's almost impossible to
get the amount of protein that a dog
needs with just plants and cats just a
fucking joke
cats are you know here's what you know
put put lay out some fucking meat and
lay out a bowl of beans see where fluffy
goes Oken down these pieces of meat you
know happy yams fluffy fucking
ridiculous
cat food shut the fuck up that thing's a
murderer man you're gonna keep keep it
keep it from being a murderer it's its
nature I mean you know it's what it does
that's what a cat does it's kind of
comedy like everybody who's been pushing
all the like the tofu and all the the
soy stuff over the last couple years
it's time to get breast cancer men you
know it's just you're discovering it's
bad for you I used to ate that stuff
instead of milk and I'd always feel sick
but I was like it's got to be healthy
for you everyone keeps telling me that
if I got man boobs that's why I have
boobs
yeah even vegan cats.com is telling
people to feed their cats meat that's
when shit gets real when vegan cats calm
tells people to feed their cats meat
after much soul-searching we've decided
that we need we only feed him asshole
cows